what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here John Humphrey well we got some
movie news for you guys before we go
into this movie news that has just been
announced I want to give a patient the
day shout out to scuba Steve because
scuba Steve does a lot of graffiti
artwork just on the streets of New York
look at some of these awesome photos
that he has here I feel like it fits
with the Joker graffitiing stuff to
share the hot house and all that I'll
you know it is I feel like it links the
scuba Steve go check out his Instagram
they follow him so you should follow him
too and I like his post so you should
like his post to scuba Steve thanks for
being here for such a good amount of
time buddy I hope that the dating sites
are working out well for you and I hope
that you get that multiple person in the
bedroom thing going for you as soon as
you can
guys this article comes from The
Hollywood Reporter Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker origin movie a go at Warner
Brothers Phoenix recently finalizes his
deal to star as the arch-nemesis of
Batman the Joker origin movie is
officially a go at Warner Brothers
Joaquin Phoenix recently finalizes the
oldest stars the arch-nemesis of Batman
and shooting is set to begin in
September in New York
Todd Phillips is directing the film and
co-wrote the strip which the studio
described as being an exploration of a
man disregarded by society that is not
only a gritty character study but also a
broader a cautionary tale Scott still
der Rohe co-wrote the script Warner says
yet to stake out a release date for the
film which goes against the grain in
most comic book movies that have flags
planted years in advance but the Joker's
standalone pic is meant to be different
from other comic book superhero movies
projects budget is in the 55 million
dollar range significantly lower than
the temples that dominate the form and
the stand alone is meant to be darker
more experimental and toning content at
least says experimental as a studio can
be with established brands such as DC
which is described as being akin to a
crime drama there's a chance movie be
ready for release as early as late 2019
ok cool it looks like Joaquin Phoenix is
officially going to play the Joker maybe
you'll be the first Joker or that really
scraggly beard I imagine he might be the
first Joker maybe with a deep
- actually I've been wanting that yeah
okay cool I know we usually have the
higher-pitched Joker voices I'm going to
need something to wear in a very big
truck and I think if you really want to
branch out and make something different
and if Warner Brothers is also having
Jared Leto continuing to be the Joker
and their continuity of the extended
universe then I think it would be smart
to actually have Joaquin Phoenix do a
deep voice Joker I think that would be
cool and I really think that some people
aren't really talking about that just my
little take hey dude create as much
contrast as possible especially because
Jared Leto's Joker hasn't left the best
taste in everyone's mouth and because
your little Joker is still gonna be
around - yeah true that and I feel like
you know this has to be a kind of a
dream come true for any actor I would
imagine even if you're not jazzed about
the idea of tentpole superhero movies if
you got offered the role the Joker I bet
most people be like whoa I got to put my
stamp on this and Joaquin Phoenix is a
terrific actor with such a sense from
mannerisms and character transformations
that gets me really excited just to see
him do it I'm wondering how old he's
gonna be for this origin story because
you know the joke origins that I know
about he's a younger guy at the time it
seems like at least younger than Joaquin
Phoenix is now well I don't think this
is really gonna be following any
specific type of graphic novel at this
point I really feel like they're going
with as much creative freedom as
possible which gets me excited because
if you're talking about doing an
experimental spin-off types of movies
yeah the Elseworlds stuff that's what
I've been wishing for since the
superhero movie became the big thing is
like when are we gonna finally branch
out into some of the weirder more
sidebar stories you know and and if this
is their first step towards the actual
Elseworlds stuff I'm really excited
about that the fact that it's only a
fifty five million dollar budget leaves
way for more trade of freedom and for
them to do something even more crazy in
terms of how violent how hard are they
want this to be because it seems like
it's headed down a path to being a
hard-r movie which i think would be
really awesome to see the Joker in a
hard-r film he's a character that kind
of deserves to be in one at this point
oh yeah well in that Joker book they put
out a couple years ago after the Dark
Knight you know yeah blew it back up
again was kind of in that vein so I
wonder if maybe it'll borrow from that a
little
yeah I think Phoenix is not known for
playing like wildly eccentric characters
he's known for transformational roles
he's known for really being in character
even when the cameras aren't rolling
with that being said I would like this
to not be the lesser version of this guy
yeah it's a pressed joke I kind of feel
like I'd be in the mood for that at this
point if you're gonna do a standalone
one do something that's just totally
different that's what I'm thinking more
subtle
deep voice Joker it could actually work
it'd be something totally different and
it would branch out I feel like you get
a first-gen for that there might be a
really mixed audience reaction for it
but if you really commit to this
transformation that would be pretty
sweet man see I can imagine Joaquin
Phoenix is a joker who's like amused a
lot of the time and only gets truly like
hugely animated and yeah like in the
most intense moments and that could be
also a really fun dynamic you know this
just opens up so many possibilities to
my head you know and I think what Todd
Phillips doing this I think he could
probably start good tone for a dark
comedy I like what he did with war dogs
for the most part it was a Scorsese want
to be filmed I think that by the time
you get to the hangover 3 the guy
clearly wants to do something that's
more of a thriller yeah he has he has a
comedy established career and I think
with the Joker you need to have a dark
comedy element so I imagine that with a
visual style that he's developed over
the years with also under having a good
grasp with comedy I think that this film
could actually work I actually have
faith in it it's it might seem weird to
release this especially since there is a
Joker already out there in the Jared
Leto form and people who don't follow
movie news might be a little bit
confused as to what's going on I imagine
that's the other thing that could happen
however for those who understand what's
going on I think is gonna be really
sweet yeah a little more optimism for
this kind of thing that isn't encumbered
by what the main DC EU plot has to be
what all the other films need to be it
seems like something like this is gonna
be allowed to be kind of its own
isolated thing yeah and that makes me
optimistic I've heard some people
whispering that the plot of this may
echo The Killing Joke in a lot of ways
or they might take direct inspiration
from that the thing with The Killing
Joke is Batman such a heavy influence in
it feel like to do a joke or origin
movie unless you're complete
we going away from the comics it'd be
very hard to not at least reference
Batman in this film or make the Batman
be known I might be cool to see Bruce
Wayne in the film but not Batman but
then you get into a whole other
territory now
like if there was to be a Batman or a
Bruce Wayne you have to cast a
completely different guy for that one
and then that could lead to more
confusion he could reference them but
not actually cast them I mean I think it
would be really awesome if to do kind of
what you've talked about in the past
where you have Batman on the fringes of
the movie like only showing up as very
outside presence very kind of yeah yeah
distance presents to the main action in
the movie could be cool but yeah that's
the thing I started to realize are
people gonna be confused there are
people who are confused about the nature
of like spider-man homecoming you know
most of us who like our all in the movie
news know the the circumstances you know
having too many Joker's and too many bad
and at the same time might be a little
cumbersome if you do have Batman in it I
think it would be cool is if you treat
the audience through the Joker's
perspective like maybe you see Bruce
Wayne and maybe you see Batman but you
never show the audience even though the
audience will know you don't directly
show the audience that Bruce Wayne and
Batman are the same person
yeah yeah you got you keep it strictly
from Joker's perspective in this movie
I'm looking forward to this one we're
like out of all the DC movies that have
been announced this is the one I'm
actually looking forward to the most
because it seems the weirdest it seems
the most experimental and at this point
I'm really down for that yeah because
it's something entirely different than
trying to emulate anything Marvel's done
in terms of movie studios I'm not
talking about comic books in terms of
movie studios yeah this is a this is a
cool path I'm ecstatic walking Phoenix
is an amazing actor it seems like the
lane words the DC you could really
actually establish it yeah give that val
kilmer Batman bags do let's do it
alright guys what do you think of this
news are you excited that Joaquin
Phoenix is officially doing this
did you see you were never really here
what about we own the night that one's
alright you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bail because subscribe button suck balls
and you can check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
is music video coverage you'd love to
have you become a veteran object to day